[Musique]
c'est une société européenne et depuis
plus de 20 ans nous concevons
construisons et exploitons des bâtiments
et campus dédiés aux entreprises et
organisations innovantes des secteurs
des sciences du vivant et des
technologies à Paris ça Clay est plus
précisément dans la ZAC du Moulon sur la
commune de Gif-sur-Yvette nous sommes en
train de concevoir avec le PA Paris
Saclay un bâtiment qui fera environ
14000 m² entièrement dédié aux sociétés
et organisations du plateau pour y
accueillir à peu près 60% de
laboratoires et les bureaux associés et
soutenir les startups les skylobs les
PME et même les grands groupes du
plateau sur des secteurs plutôt de la
santé agro et également tout ce qui
concerne la clintech la greentech
notamment qui exprime des besoins en
termes de laboratoire bsl2 et espace de
bioproduction
la conception du bâtiment est faite par
la agence d'architecture charte et
d'Alix que nous avons retenu à l'issue
d'un concours avec une conception très
modulaire à la fois dans son plan masse
dans son architecture puisqu'elle est
conçue autour de 4 plots qui sont reliés
par un atrium central et des espaces
communs généreux et au sein des espaces
privatifs de laboratoire et de bureaux
nous prévoyons une grande modularité
entre le laboratoire et le bureau pour
offrir les deux types de surfaces des 50
mètres carrés et jusqu'à plusieurs
milliers la conception la construction
et l'exploitation du bâtiment
s'inscriront dans une démarche
environnementale très ambitieuse avec
une attention à la consommation de
carbone selon les futurs réglementations
environnementales et revint RER 25 le
choix de la pierre comme matériaux de
façade a été très naturel tant pour
l'architecte que pour le PA et cadence
et la municipalité dans son choix
puisque
c'est un matériau qui est bas carbone
qui viendra de la région et qui sera
très pérenne dans dans le temps par
ailleurs il y aura une production sur
site de d'électricité avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques en toiture
donc l'ouverture du bâtiment pour les
futurs occupants est prévue en 2026 qui
devrait accompagner la livraison du
l'ouverture du de la ligne de métro qui
arrive à quelques mètres de l'immeuble
[Musique]